is when we look at the excellent records
of the first, second, third century
Christians, all of them say that these
are efficacious for salvation that
they're not just symbolic that they have
an actual datifying effect on the person
that receives them. So, I guess my
question is, how can you say that you're
following what the Bible says if your
interpretation of the Bible is not
lining up with the people that directly
received the Bible and even compiled the
canon of the New Testament?
If that's true, then what's the history
of why so many millions upon millions
don't think it's the case? You can argue
the same thing about why so many people
don't believe in the gospel. I mean,
that's that's just No, no, but who are
the people? I I want you to say, now
notice the argument. If that's true, why
there are so many millions that don't
believe it? I mean, is that a response
uh because of the Protestant
Reformation? Because when the
reformation took place in when the
reformers articulated solos scriptor to
scriptura that scriptur is the ultimate
authority everyone then felt they were
qualified to tell you what the text
means doesn't mean so that even among
the magisterial reformers you had Martin
Luther debating uric zwingley on the
basis of solos scripter to scripter
whether the eucharist was truly the body
blood of Christ or symbolic. I mean,
what kind of response is that? And then
if we use that
argument, don't you have millions who
read the Bible but reject the Trinity,
reject the deity of Christ? Don't you
have millions who either think Christ is
the first creature of the father or that
Jesus is the human manifestation of the
father? Uh what kind of argument is
that? Can someone help me
understand? I I don't understand that
argument. He's talking about the first
centuries of the Christian church.
First, second, third centuries, right?
And he's asking him to show him, did
anyone deny that Eucharist is the flesh
and blood of our Lord Jesus Christ? The
church fathers and who you're referring
to on both sides of the fence? Well,
there's no both sides because we don't
have any records of anyone that loses.
So, you're saying it later with Luther?
Not either. Notice he said church
fathers.
Martin Luther is not a church
father. This is what happens and I say
this with the hope that the spirit will
convict Clifton and his son Stewart.
This is what happens when you speak off
the cuff and out of pride you want to be
right. Church fathers Martin Luther is a
church
father. You you he said church fathers
what do you do with Martin Luther? I
didn't know Martin Luther was a church
father. But now watch how it's going to
backfire. Yes, Martin Luther actually
did
believe that the
Eucharist is not just bread and wine and
substance, but the Eucharist you also
take in the actual physical flesh and
blood of Jesus Christ. Of all the people
you could quote, Martin Luther, Martin
Luther was adamant that when Jesus said,
"This is my body, this is my blood, take
him literally." Did you guys know that?
Even with Luther because Luther famously
said he would rather drink blood with
the pope than how did it come about? It
came with oling and some of the radical
reformers which is like what 500 years
ago. He was naming and he's naming him.
Name some. He goes it came with Ulwing
and some of the radical reformists. He
is naming them. Give him a chance Cliff
Stewart. Give him a chance. What does it
matter to be? What matters is if we're
believing in Christianity as
historically the records of first
century Christians that lived in the
time of the apostles that would believe
the belie. Right my friend during that
time period not everybody thought that
literally Jesus was eating his own body
and drinking his own blood. Yeah. What?
Now let me explain rhetoric. I need you
to listen. Class has begun. Let me
explain to you rhetoric. In order to
scandalize a viewpoint or
demonize your
interlocutor, you're going to use
language in order to evoke shock and
disgust. You see what he did? He turned
the topic to that Jesus ate his own
flesh, his own body, drank his own
blood. Why? to scandalize the audience
to shock them and being embarrassing
embarrassed to accept this. No, no, no,
no, no, no. Jesus ate his flesh, drank
his blood. Wow, that's blasphemy. What's
ironic though, here's what's ironic. Do
you know who used a similar form of
argument, guys? Learn your
history, and I learned this from when I
was an anti-atholic because Catholics
and Orthodox brought it up. Do you know
who used this argument to scandalize
Christians, demonize Christians to get
them killed? The pagans. The pagans said
Christians were
cannibals and atheists. Did you know
that the
early
pagans when they heard Christians
talking about eating the body and
drinking the blood of their God Jesus
Christ, they said, "These guys are
cannibals.
Why would they accuse them of can
cannibalism if the Christians weren't
teaching that at the Eucharist, the Holy
Spirit made the bread and wine into the
physical body and blood of
Jesus. They also said fact don't listen.
Thank Jesus for internet. It can be used
to glorify Christ or sadly to sin. May
we never use it to sin. Pay your
internet bill. Stop using your
neighbor's internet. Don't be that
cheap.
Google it. Google chat GBT. After all,
Lilith, right, Lily? He used GBT to
prove
Islam. Chat GBT and Google the
greatest Messiah the world has ever
seen. The early pagans said Christians
are atheists and cannibals.
Christians are
atheists and cannibals.
Why? Because they denied the existence
of the gods and goddesses of the pagans
and were saying they were eating the bo
body and drinking the blood of their god
Jesus.
Do you know
that you won't get that
reaction response if you taught the
bread and wine are merely figures,
symbols? I'll be getting into Justin
Martyr fight league. It's in my
article. No, no, no. John, he said
Vatican
3, but this is an emotional rant, an
emotional response. Can I refute my own
objection? Because once I came to accept
it, once I came to accept what the early
church taught and I realized I was
wrong, I asked the Lord to help me
understand how to respond to his
objection because that's what they bring
up. I because later he's going to mock.
So what Jesus dipped his kneecap in his
blood later on he's going to mock. I
want you to listen.
He's going to actually mock the real
presence by later on saying, "So you're
saying Christ took his kneecap, dipped
it in his
blood?" Yeah. The book is called Not by
How many times? I'm going to show you
right
here. You can even get this as a PDF
from his site. Okay? You want me to show
you how to respond to that? I asked the
Lord to help me once I accepted it.
What does God
do? Faith precedes knowledge. There's a
saying that I've heard attributed
to Augustine. The saying is faith
precedes knowledge. What does he
mean? God will start giving you wisdom,
illumination knowledge when you take a
step of faith. Let me tell you how it
works. If you have already made up your
mind what God can and cannot be and what
God can and cannot do, then God hands
you over to your beliefs so that you can
feel justified. Let me repeat, I've seen
this multiple people my own life and in
the Bible. This is a principle you must
learn and I'm going to show you how it
applied to me. When you've already made
up your mind, when you've already made
up your
mind what God can and cannot
be, what God can and cannot
do, and you don't allow God to be who he
is, he gives you the desires of your
heart. He will then send you teachers to
tickle your ears and give you what you
want to believe. 2 Timothy 4:es 1-5.
But if you take a step of faith and you
tell God, "I'm wrong and you tell God,"
I don't know as much as I think. And you
tell God, "I am willing to accept
whatever you say and I'll believe
whatever you say and I'll accept you as
you are, but just show me and convince
me right that this is right." Once you
do that, then he'll open your eyes and
ears and everything will fall into
place. You with me there? So when I
would not accept and believe these
doctrines, God allowed me to come up
with arguments that I thought were
irrefutable. The moment I said, "All
right, I have to give in." Need you to
listen to this. I have to give in to the
evidence of the early church. I believe
the promise of scripture. Christ is
building his church. The Holy Spirit
filled the apostles and filled their
successors, the bishops to be their
replacement and would keep raising up
true
bishops. Empower them the same we
empowered the apostles and empower these
true bishops to preserve scriptures,
their interpretation, and destroy the
heresies and expose the heretics. And
then I believe that promise. Christ is
real. He cannot lie. and I see who the
true bishops were and they taught this.
All right, I accept
it. Then the answer came to me. I
deleted one of my old older articles
called
Questions on the Mass. I had on my blog
an article years ago thinking I was
smart, thinking I was sharpening the
arguments of other anti-atholics to
refute the mass, I deleted it. One of
the points I
made, why is Jesus eating his own flesh,
drinking his own blood, and I go, "Aha,
slam dunk."
Once
once I humbled myself and said, "This is
what the Christians taught. All right,
I'm going to accept it." Then the answer
came to me. Now, you want to know what
the answer is? This is how God will
reward your faith. What does Hebrews
11:6 say?
Right? It is impossible to please God
without faith.
Four, you must believe he
is and that he rewards those who
earnestly seek him. Hebrews 11:6. Let me
repeat. For without faith it is
impossible to please God. Again, let me
repeat. Hebrews 11:6. Without faith, it
is impossible to please God.
Four, you must believe he exists and
that he rewards those who earnestly seek
him. You see, when you believe he is, as
he claims to be, and you earnestly seek
him to make himself known as he is,
he'll reward you. Hebrews 11:6.
So now that I did that, now here's the
answer. You ready? It was so simple. I
laughed. I go, damn, how stupidly
arrogant I am. I laughed. Can I ask you
guys a
question? I want to ask you a
question. You ready? Hopefully I'll have
time for Q&A because I know God logic is
going live. I may have to do it later.
Can I ask you a question?
If Jesus doesn't transform the bread and
wine into his body and blood, is it his
body and
blood? Answer me so you can see how easy
it is to refute the
stupidity. Isn't it? If the Lord God,
the triune God, does not change the
bread and wine into the physical body
and blood of Christ, is it the body and
blood of Christ?
Okay, answer me, mods. You're going to
have to be quicker.
Okay, now can Jesus do this
miracle? Here's where it came to me. And
I promise you, I didn't hear someone say
this. I was just reflecting, Lord, now
that I believe, how do I respond? So,
here's my second question. That same
Jesus Almighty, can he make that bread
and
wine, his body and blood, when the
disciples take it, but not make it the
body and blood when he eats the bread
and drinks the wine? Can he do
that? Is Jesus able to do that? So that
when Jesus takes that bread and eats it,
drinks the wine, he doesn't make that
his body and blood for him, but he makes
it for Peter, John, and James when they
take it and drink it cuz they need it.
He
doesn't. There's your answer. See how
simple it was? Too simple, right? That
even a kid could figure it out. That's
the
blessing. That's the reward. When you
say, "Lord, I believe. Lord, help my
unbelief. Lord, I take you at your word.
I will accept that it's the flesh and
blood of Christ." And then God says,
"Now that you've humbled yourself, now
let me give you the
answer." Do you see the answer now?
You get my
point? Now that you humbled yourself,
Sam, now I'm going to give you the
answer.
Sam, don't be stupid. I'm the Almighty
God. When Peter takes the bread and
takes the wine, I by the spirit with me
turn it into my flesh and blood for him
and for John and for Thomas. But I don't
do it for me because I don't need
to.
Right? This is what Hebrews 11:6 is all
about.
This is what Hebrews 11:6 is all about.
Without faith, it is
impossible to please him. For he who
sees God must believe he is. And that
means the rewarder of all those who seek
him earnestly. And how does he reward
you?
Right? by telling you and explaining to
you. But he won't if you are
adamant. He won't if you insist it can't
be true. He won't if you keep telling
him, "No, you can't be triune. You can't
be a man. You can't be born of a virgin.
You can't. No, you can't. Can't can't."
Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't know that I am
obligated to be what you want me to be
and to do what you want me to do. And I
didn't know that I'm limited by what you
think I can and cannot do. Forgive me. I
didn't know you were God over
me.
Right. Yep. Exactly. Ralph, you now you
see the insight, the light switch,
right, Ralph? See, Ralph, now it made
sense. This is my body broken for you.
This cup is my blood shed for
you. See, now it makes sense,
huh? Make
sense? So that's how you answer this
guy.